how's it going bros my name is P anyway
welcome back to Musa the dark descend
Redemption if you remember uh-oh
let's get me more than last time wholly
impossible oh maybe if I pull one other
levers oh okay
pull the penis I pull the penis I'm
pulling penis I'm pulling penis I'm
pulling fears every day that's what I
I'm just kidding anyway we're back in
English like everyone's like you forgot
to talk Swedish no I don't forget the
taxes all right done so many
commentaries in English it's just it's
just weird for me to do it in Swedish I
all I'll do it one more time but not for
now I'm working on a different project
so I didn't have time to put all this on
college and I boy what do you thing
about I have a share I don't now Katie I
think you're pretty goddamn I do Jerry
Oh mister share that with a brow I don't
know I don't miss you scared so
oblivious hello yeah hello sexy
mr. Shah can you read lift not for me
all right sure I already find pity I'm
not lying about would you start a look
down I have no idea why but all I know
is that I heard a huge bang like a door
was being cracked open for my scream
that's an accident or something I think
I'm a mister sir but that doesn't open
lock down that explain lock down that
doesn't if I whatever jeez class don't
touch me pee now that doesn't you all
right oh well but it's not so bad it's
kind of cozy
there's knocks on the door wait there's
a knock and she have a baby on the
doubter actually I wasn't me ah you did
this this is up now it down appreciate
pity take a shower I was just kidding
you just cries you're such a drama queen
Irene jeez you're crying alright why
this stop breaking stuff [ __ ] that was
yeah even me yes right alright wait
Kenny what is this get go
all right there why did we go go up the
ladder we go I'm glad it would go Oh bro
Oh
Oh bro bro oh the lighter we go go up
the ladder we go up the ladder we go go
hey oh hey bro I don't I don't trust you
he's all around just that get it put it
back put it back put it back put it back
put it back put it back good enough for
me I'm just yeah huh what the [ __ ] bro
what the black dahlia dress dear you can
never trust how you doing buddy hi I'm
doing with your penis I don't get this
what are you doing here I don't know
Jesus Christ loud I'm talking English
again good actually I was stuck in
English anyway it was trying to rape you
baby you're lucky to be alive
I am actually an undercover cop I've
been while studying this case for a
month we finally got him good jeopardy
the [ __ ] all right this way PD we have
to continue this map down huh what's
that it's the bow all right I can do
this now I hate you
really is that a coincidence or maybe no
it's impossible it's impossible PD look
oh oh
it's going this way Stefano it's your
left go right go pay the bat all night
go up go down I don't even know what's
the sound yeah
where's hoppity-hop eating how about God
somebody share uh okay how about pretty
ahh
let's get out of here I got the machine
room key why is it always a machine room
key I I don't know most cars
oh oh oh no bro no bro no bro bro is it
Bobo I got them
you were lucky to look at me otherwise
you probably had be in your pants like
that buddy
oh god another ladder I have to say
goodbye to fauna can we throw them up no
I can't
Hey oh Jesus Christ Billy I hate you hey
amber
well you always do this to me always
every single time you leave me alone in
the darkness for a [ __ ] ladder yeah
all right no I can open hey goddamn back
oh there's nothing there what is this
place what it what's going on here well
I just came from now it's impossibly
what am I talking like Stefan oh Carlos
I don't like her
oh no this mission e78 guys teleporting
naked guy good I [ __ ] yeah why are
you telling am i playing naked
I am busy on your that's my piss effect
we can go okay ah ha painting how do you
got scared out there I said that mr.
chef hey brah you scared I'm never
scared I'm a sheriff and I know a secret
about not being scared come come sit by
to bed with me beating I'll explain it
for you alright here's the thing it's
got schambach I actually heard enough a
nice animal came out is happy so if you
care more is happy I yeah best song yeah
I'm gonna sing today I get a loading
[ __ ]
see this is why I waste my liner because
I always get oil anyway so it's like
whatever why are you wasting about that
why are you wasting don't know if you're
laughing ah
babies are because we keep hey how you
doing I climbed the status for hours and
hours in here I am finally all right
I'll say this one for you we're still in
lockdown this is getting too much
seriously
we have been like this for hours without
any guidance on what we should do and
this is like the second time one month
this month I can't read all right I
guess I'll just have to wait it out are
you gonna wait in our spot
no that's really I've been in a weight
that once it didn't go very bad what
happened tell me yeah it was prostitutes
involved and a lot of people what upset
I don't want to get into it okay Jesus
Christ
have some respect there are we walking
backwards
alright the why the [ __ ] away are we mad
we really how do we is that do you think
I thought whoa did you see that door
damn I don't even know what's caught
whoa whoa you see that that's why I'm
Stefan
Hey all these rooms identical or did I
already been in this one hey hey he's
putting a tank ago rooms
it's not fair I need to find a key Hey
okay I check the other rooms first I
don't trust this one alright girl and
boy hey find a key for the machine room
key there's always the machine room key
always every mod I guess everyone use
that key for whatever
hello I guess they could just copy this
scripts from the regular anisha yes I'm
doing a regular commentary hey Stefano
this way
Oh what is that it's dark it's so good I
don't even know all right should we go
here first I don't trust this door I
said you'd side
wait I'd close it and then enlarge
that's kind of creepy whatever I just go
I just go over here huh see that I threw
him up and then I clicked the door and
then I'll catch him winning loads uh-huh
oh that would have been wanted this
Jesus Christ
oh wow I was gonna say bro but then he
Kim's mom and I said mo
huh oh now they're closing it would have
been no no I why no why tell me why
these all these doors closed tell me
what I don't cause you and your penis
never trust any penises all right pity I
know how you feel
let me do this one for you all right
share moat [ __ ] activate it Oh
once we feel like oh good what is he
doing I told him not to do anything
until I told him I told him not to do
anything until I tell them I told her
not to do anything until I tell them is
that a paradox I told him not to do
anything until I tell them I can can't
recall charge power pressure net not
gonna have to spare the gondala matter
I don't besan there's ever I die I'm not
the dog is getting old anyway I have to
kill him
you call me Whitney bride patient honor
it's been a while just you and me now I
know we have our differences but I just
want to say I love you and I always here
for you no matter what thank something
happens how're the hollers be here mr.
fan out mmm natural much
I said nachos it sounds like nachos but
you're walking attackers again Petey how
about that are you
this is this real is that Aurelio mr.
Sherr hey wait what's going on here
why - why all the rooms I date I don't
trust this [ __ ]
I like men he makes big mass but wow
frickin frackin hey I'm walking in
circles
oh stop please oh no oh no no lah I'm
supposed to go here apparently how long
every quarry 11 minutes Oh No Kia
modeski and SEO
the key is that's it
he got out I have the key I have the
frickin frackin freaking Eve up it's at
the red one yes it is let's go in some
five [ __ ] you bro ouch ouch ouch ouch
ouch ouch ouch ouch to hurt my leg out
I fell for like 50 meters how is it even
possible
I'm gonna take my line out of him and
you guys can get sugar go there latin
anima hey what is it a caution huh oh
the cold is trying to kill me
now oh god oh god it's creeping up on me
the clock oh no the closet ah anything
but the closet now closet grows
everywhere
this is why I love things math they're
just so [ __ ] intense
thank you Frank big feedback and all I
can't start should I continue yes you
should
that was his first map I think it's
pretty dang good fridge first man like
I'll get mine at apply I'm just kidding
this awesome I don't even know what I'm
talking about
[ __ ] this like every day I get freaking
heart attack it can't be healthy I don't
I don't even know anymore but anyway I
hope you enjoyed this video if you let
your food be I don't even know if
favorite helps anymore like they've
changed the entire YouTube cyst I have
no idea how the [ __ ] boy likes house
at least so that's it
[Music]
[Music]
that's Kavita fresh bamboo shock fair
it's safe pay there you can go